this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
welcome to EE 380 Stanford computer
systems laboratory colloquium fall 2012
2013 this is the last talk of the
quarter
I'm Andy Freeman the other course
organizers Dennis Allison I'd like to
remind students taking the class to get
all your assignments in knowing
completes today's lecture is part of the
computer science departments
distinguished lecture series so the
speaker introduction will be done by
Professor Lee thank you Andy
so yes welcome to the computer science
department distinguished lecture series
in fact this is the first one of the
academic year we have one per quarter
and we highly encourage students to
attend these very high-quality talks my
name is Faye Faye Lee I work at the CAS
department as a part of the AI lab
faculty so it's a great honor to really
have Harry dr. Harry Shum here is a
long-term friend colleague and mentor
and has given me a lot of great advice
along the years and I guess Palo Alto is
so honored to have Harry it offers you
the Seattle weather as welcome
so Harry is really one of the most
distinguished luminaries in the areas of
computer graphics computer and computer
vision he's he graduated in from CMU
with the PhD specializing in graphics
and then he was just telling us his
distinguished career he actually did the
Silicon Valley thing which is a startup
and then and then Harry said that two
things don't mix in life was startup and
baby so he decided to he had his first
son he decided to go to Microsoft
research what a great choice we wouldn't
have had been and a lot of great things
so Harry was part of the founding team
of Microsoft Research Asia
researching in China and then renamed
Microsoft Research Asia and that was
around the time I personally met Harriet
he has just he was just tremendous he
built an incredible research team there
every year you just see dozens of papers
published in C Grapher computer vision
from Microsoft Research Asia and he did
so well I think probably Bill Gates or
whoever personally invited him back to
Microsoft as a corporate VP to to head
the Bing development team so without
further ado let me hand over this podium
to Harry he's going to tell us about
interesting things he did that Thank You
Fifi I was really worried that you know
if I can add any value to Stanford
especially back to the CS department I
used to hang out with McAvoy Pat Chris
brechler those guys when I was walking
on visioning the graphics but I thought
at least I'm already making some
contribution by bringing Seattle rings
I'm sure you guys here need a little bit
more water I used to work as a
researcher in Microsoft for many years
and until five and a half years ago then
I was kicked out of research and got a
real job that is the hacking codes and
the beauty of Microsoft's the changing
before I talk a lot about some of the
details whatever to whatever extent I
can share with you about what we do in
Bing and let me also cavea that and
given that I'm no longer a seriously
researcher now I'm and lowly engineer
hacking code there's very few equations
in this presentation and they're very
shallow as well hopefully you know you
also find some value out of this
presentation so stem freeze place that
you know as the CMU graduate that I want
to be especially respectful so before I
actually get into my presentation I
actually really like to do that and just
to make sure that I understand this
audience
how many of you here have heard about
the Bing Wow so how many of you have
used the Bing Wow this so far so good
okay how many of you how many of you
regularly use Bing and now now we hit
the problem and I think you think we
should get the names that make sure that
we send them some t-shirts and so so
let's that's that's one of the problems
I'd like to just share with you and in
this battle with Google and there I just
almost impossible however you interpret
even that's you know we have what the
two hands III have a chance to talk to
Hector this morning and happily said
he's a Chrome default search to Bing
just so you know that you can actually
do that and then just for the heck half
out of this and they're just for fun and
how many of you he actually worked for
Google that's good and I just that is a
question for you you have and so even
that you know would be very transparent
about what we do and the title of my
talk is actually intend knowledge and in
the user interaction is really mostly
how we think about how to design the
product the user experience so let me
start by saying it has been quite a
journey building search engine in
Microsoft I just want to make sure that
you know we actually have a little bit
of historical perspective you know how
difficult the problem was and the still
is I did not really plot you know a lot
of historical data let me just say that
ever since the Google happened which was
a great thing and I happened to write
here the Stanford and ever since the
Google happens and they are Google just
moved like this and they're just eating
lunch from every other search engine
competitor in the right list of because
the product the quality was so much
different and you can see that from 2005
to 2009 and the post Yahoo and the
Microsoft lost no 10 points each and
Google actually picked up 20 points and
I stopped that here is actually really
when actually we start you get very
serious and they relaunched the product
as Bing
so we worried about it and that we care
about such and we talk to a lot of
industry analysts and the people know
experts like Danny Sullivan and then he
actually rised this that the block if
you actually ever care about a search
and you should regularly read a nice
block is actually called a search engine
comm he came just the other fairly
frequently during that period of time so
we talked to him and I actually
shamelessly plagiarized his picture you
know this Google cigarette his point of
view was that snow still very valid is
saying that Google has become such a
strong brand it's actually even beyond
apparent it's almost like a brushing
teeth and there is almost becoming a
habit and I habit doesn't mean the good
habit so i habit could be mean like a
smoking so for those of you regularly
use google just go home and think about
every time you use google in this like a
smoking google and it doesn't kill you
as then he said but it could be harmful
so so that's really when we actually
look at all those difficult problems and
hopefully you know you will enjoy this
video actually put together by our
marketing colleagues and their it's
really know started our journey
multi-tier mission to give us new life
so you know I actually I'm just going to
make some marketing jokes and that I
some day I'm done with my engineering
career I would really want to move to
marketing department it's a lot of fun
all you need to spend the money and the
creating creating creating videos and
but really in the jokes aside a lot of
people ask me how did you guys come up
with this name Bing in there and there
was a lot of hypotheses and there's a
pins not Google so be ing serbians land
but it's not Google and there's a lot of
things and we have internal jokes as
well but I give you official answer why
we actually named I was the changing
being so the fact is that you know as we
get more and more online use search
engines more and more and we just become
lazy and the we actually start to forget
about things and the in fact and I
myself I actually don't even remember a
lot of phone numbers anymore and now I
can hardly remember my wife's because
it's all stop there similarly for any
kind of interesting things and such as
the website and they just don't remember
anymore because they have a search
engine so the hope is really as time
goes on we will all forget about no
six-letter words and they the only thing
we can remember about the four-letter
words and by then I think you can only
remember being so so then we will win so
so we have come a long way in the sense
that we launched being so I'll share
with you a few numbers I feel very proud
of our team and the engineering
marketing that all together so in the in
the US the unique users we actually have
increased by about the thirds now we
have roughly about 100 million unique
users monthly and the bean market this
year and I you saw the picture before
and by the time we launched this new
brand being in June of 2009 we had only
about 8% of the market share so now we
have actually about 16% of market share
we also power Yahoo spec n so plus
Yahoo's we have actually close to not
quite but close to 30% of the share in
United States and one thing we have done
very well is actually brand awareness
you know clearly that everyone in this
room heard about the being so it's an
edit awareness is basically saying you
on street ask any random Joe is just say
you know have you heard about the
pinioned actually clearly a lot of
people united states now actually know
Bing as a brand it's actually not easy
so the quality is really getting better
so that's something that me as the head
of the engineering future mend asleep
routes no I hope throughout my talk you
know with a lot of examples here and the
you go home give it a try
I do feel our quality is at the point
that I deserve x' to get another look
from you so that's the thing I show you
a few you know quotes no we can't
constantly talk to people like Danny and
then is saying the most important point
that is that Google is not always better
let's just be clear I show you some
examples in my talk this other no
analyst a was worse than as a look and
they look at the interface is good it's
fast and most importantly it's actually
relevance so there's a someone actually
has been writing in the yearly post
about the policy of the superior
so changing the point is really
something I want to make that as well
try to yourself and see know if you
really agree with me and see you know
how good paying such quality is in the
end of the day is the most important
thing for search engine is finding stuff
that you're looking for and that's first
in the foremost is still the core
problem and I do want to just share a
little bit experience with you that you
know it is a consumer product it is a
brand it's very very difficult to build
if we look historically and those things
that happens you know a few very famous
brand Wars happen especially in the
United States the most favorite famous
ones of course in the Coke versus Pepsi
is this famous Pepsi challenge and is
just say you know you take a no sip see
you know if the Pepsi is actually better
than no Coke or vice-versa
no I would say I'd be happy to take a
Pepsi smoky share any day you know if I
ping can get there no it's the coke is
still winning but the I think Pepsi has
done a really good job so the others the
second example I have is actually is
versus hurts I mean it's really hard to
differentiate you got to realize I mean
go to rental car what more can you
really provide to other people and my
rental car is better than yours and it's
just very very difficult but the least
avis has this tagline say you know what
we try harder and in this day of time
and the unfortunate consumers don't
really give them a say you try harder so
therefore I am going to use you
I think it's not clear to me you know
it's really that a great example and the
sudden you have Madonna versus the
Burger King and have FedEx versus DHA
all the tons of examples there and but
as long as this industry is still making
a lot of money people will have no
second product coming and they try to
compete so what we have done we have
done a lot of things and over the last
three years and the latest one is
actually something we call the pinger
the arm ping challenge it's really a
website you can give it a try it's
called a ping it on.com and there's a
big challenge so you can actually go to
that website and I think about the five
queries you want to compare and then you
vote which one wins and this really the
blind test if you really look at
carefully you probably still can't
figure out that which phone the color
really used by Google and but if you
don't look too carefully you can ignore
all the branding effects and you look at
that so we actually did some user study
the fact we found that you know a lot of
users actually prefer the Bing results
but it's really hard to say and I talked
to you know a lot of people you know we
try to come up with this industry forum
why don't we just bring all the search
engines to Google being Yandex Baidu and
come together have this industry forum
and maybe can just happen here in
Stanford compared with such quality
agree on sudden metrics that you cannot
measure and then we see you know how it
goes but then it hasn't happened yet
so we started this thing in a call to
ping it on and you can take a look at
that and let me know you know your feel
founds you know if you are pleasantly
surprised that the ping is actually
doing pretty well and they give you the
try so that's the thing and but this
isn't really no guarantee you know we
have been no TV ads and online ads and
they try to convince people to give it a
try
and with no some moderate success I
would say it's really hard the key point
is that consumer consumer brand is
really really hard and let me show you a
video in the you may have seen and on
some of your local TV stations let me
hope you have same appreciation as I do
know for marketing folks and when they
showed me this they said people prefer
being over Google two to one I am I
almost fainted I said that here goes my
scientific research career by making
this such claims and at least my name is
really not associate so let me just show
you a couple of examples by no mean I'm
saying no that no a couple of examples
really saying you know thing is
definitely better than Google not I'm
just encouraging to really give it a try
and everyday as I told me the singer
every day every morning I get up I used
Google I just have tremendous respect
for Google engineers so what they have
done the search quality they have
improved over the years in the
incredible job it really brings the best
out of the Bing engineering team as well
and they I feel very motivated every day
competing with Google I show you an
example and I don't know why Google
didn't get it and
for those working at Google maybe you
can go back and ask them and the query
is actually why Google is no longer king
and is actually as a blogger actually
wrote this blog who is the tide of why
Google is no longer King and Bing got it
at number one and Google doesn't and who
we just did not get this result and not
that number one not at the first page
and I clicked a couple of pages I didn't
find anywhere so just the examples
enough the examples you will feel in
those so my suggestion to you is that
you know at least the next time you try
if you don't find something Google give
being a chance and give it a try let's
be very clear that search is such a
difficult problem it's just so difficult
and it's just it's it's it's just that
the users are not very cooperative and
they often type things wrong and the
people like me who are not native
speakers you know very often have
problems and really use this spelling
right and they are are those last name
for example sewers in the guy and I can
never really spell and I suspected
no probably no more than a couple of
people can really spell but now that you
don't really worry about you go to
search engine you actually give it a try
and that they actually correct them for
you so I'll give you an example here say
we actually believe that this user
really meant the nicotine withdraw
withdraw and so this guy just typed this
thing and there I actually think we got
it right and we look at the google
spelling results we respectfully
disagree with Google here we probably
get it the more right maybe but do you
never know you just never know and so I
give you another example google has done
better which is much to my dismay I am
here in stem for I really want to pay
the respect to John and we try to tie
with John Hennessey and then we actually
end up with John Kennedy and the Google
actually that's right I guess there are
Larry and the circuit did to pay more
attention to any name you know from
Stanford you know so
yeah I'm sure it's a positive virus you
know no you know you got you got you got
to you got to absolutely push this a mi
mi key limbs down you know and make sure
those stem four names up so my point
here is that it just say it's a very
difficult problem for many many years
and the part of the Google magic is
there spelling and they talk to you mate
you talk to those guys they're in the
quarantine team you would absolutely see
the sense of pride you know from that
game and I want to make it very clear
that our internal numbers shows that
however you measure this fellow quality
and with latest the release from being
doing neck-to-neck and be happy to talk
to those folks more it's just it's a
hard problem none of us really gets it
right every time so it probably makes
sense that you know there are more
search engines really competing just
like do you research so talking about
the search quality that's again it's
really the most important thing that
foster change and we work really hard in
the look at the overall the search
quality and anytime you have an
engineering problem you have to have
some kind of metrics and you have to be
very clear especially as a head of
engineering I have to stand up every six
months telling my teams so that's what I
care for the last five plus years I have
been extremely consistency it's only
three things I actually care about such
quality that's the relevance performance
and the experience so relevancy just
really goes really goes without the
saying you just have to make sure that
you get the right the results you get
this is a better result on top and
simple is that performance no one's
going to wait for two seconds to get
these results and it's extremely
important it's a huge investment at
backend and from your data center to
your network issue no it's a rendering
and you have to really think about entry
and a lot of problems a lot of
engineering problems there the last one
is really it's a consumer product and
it's really about user experience I was
talking to you the host of this class
and the lecture of this class in there
before him he study I didn't get his
name is that he has many problems
questions for me afterwards is there
overall that the way to really
such with a white box with a few words
is this really even the right thing to
do I think we can debate about that but
no way we're not advertising revenue pay
attention to them I do but I I don't
have time to talk about that and then
advertising revenue for sure and I look
and I never had the chance to really
talk to Larry in the surgery let me just
hypothesize that that's the night he
recognized how much money it was seeking
oh I bet they couldn't sleep that night
and then you go from a fun research
project proper grade your student
project you know she really seemed as an
unbelievable business model that you can
make it so much more money and it's
really very important but for this
particular talk I'm going to focus on
use the experience here such an
experience here so I really want to just
to slowly take your Surya there's a kind
of you know very important recognition
from my point of view and from being
engineering point of view however you
really think about is a user experience
and the more or less step in the four
three five four or five years ago it was
more or less that's you know it was
really what I called a such hit or miss
model it's really about you give you
give a query then we give you ten
results back it's all the web documents
mostly so the job there is really
understanding the query enough you know
lexically and then we indexing the words
and try to do matching then we try to
compute the relevance end of the day the
result is really the relevance of the
temple links ten web documents so put
that mathematically what this really
means is really minimizing the time of
query URL matching so you really want to
get the query and the URL match and they
get you how do they a lot of this
queries the early days is really mostly
navigational is research do you want to
get to this particular Walmart if
somewhere summit Helen or so so that's
really the the model for many many years
has been very successful with the simple
white box in we get a lot of the
information you need but we actually
believe that it's really getting to know
the next stage more animals people use
search engines they are not satisfied
who is only getting to a particular
website
they actually come to search engine with
something in mind some kind of task to
see mine it just don't really know how
to express the intent so we really need
to understand the intent more
contextually about the user about the
locations about other things and we
really need to get into more details and
a lot more semantic meanings about the
documents as well and so that we can
actually match better so then it's
really talking about the relevance it's
not only just the query to the URL to
the document is really the query to the
URL and these entities and the taste
here are really just a proxy of you know
what is really the what knowledge really
used here and the Danny I would say you
know mathematically you know this
problem can be really redefined as
really about the minimizing the time for
the user to complete the task
previously really minimizing time of
query URL matching which is still
important it's still kernel of this
whole problem but I would say I'd like
to reformulate this such problem to
minimizing time of task accomplishing
accepted that is that very difficult a
problem you don't know the task you just
don't know the task the user has no
ability and there we cannot design the
right in the interface for the user to
express what exactly is that on the way
back to work I just heard from the NPR
this is this new drug you know this is
some researchers you know somewhere some
organizing here in Seattle and some guy
did something and with some name I don't
know no Kathy no some guy's name and
then so then you try to piece something
together really want to get to that
there's a young researcher and the who's
the father is actually Stanford
professor where'd you did that and
somehow you know many many steps later
you actually get that so it's really not
about one particular search is really
more about the entire session and the
whether you can really get there so I
really think that the week getting there
if you think if you agree that is really
what people are searching for then you
actually have no choice but the design
the product as a dialogue
it's really step by step to carries the
user to what does the user was really
looking for I think that's why we
actually say you know we have to go to a
dialogue model and the providing more
useful more relevant information every
single step but Ouisa objective in mind
at the end of the day it's really about
getting to the past competition yes so
you think that's because people assume
that search engines can you know process
a very complex query and then they do a
dialogue based model or do you think
that's essentially how humans work I
think it is probably post here's how I
think about this I think that we of
course care the trains and mostly by
Google and the other search engines as
well so cup train say well you try
something if you don't get that now that
you got discouraged I mean the humans
are more less the lean reinforcement
learning machines so then you look at
this say well if you cannot get a lot of
things then you just don't try but of
course you know people forget you know
they I try again and then you have the
younger generation they actually are
more brave to try those different things
and the days also I would say the
technology wise is just not that easy to
do and if you look at the where we are
in terms of search engine fine the large
is still more or less you know what we
do is the web graph what do we do is the
web graph where each document is
actually index small as just the words
and we're adding more the more metadata
we actually injecting more and more
entity and the relationship and those
things but this architecture today is
more or less stays the same
and there are reasons for example that
you go to you know Google for example
you flee input modern so the two
characters and the rest it will be
ignored
and there's a reason for that is not
badly can not do more and there's an
economical reasons why you don't really
process that much so I think it is
really both size and the technology is
not ready and that people keep the try
and they get something if they don't
then they move on we need to design the
system in a way that is the experience
needs to be good enough so the user will
continue to try then they continue give
you more data then you have a chance to
improve
if you have the perfect search and then
you think people is still engaged in
time this is no such a thing how the
professor yeah and so I I actually love
this such a few because I used to hook
up research to me I think is such is
such a perfectly relevant right because
you don't really know the answer you
struggle to define even a metric what
you are really optimizing I'm I'm
presenting one particular way of looking
at this problem but it's just a
particular way if we bet it on right and
we might make a lot of good progress you
will bet it wrong too bad okay so that's
really the way we look at then you say
well then how to put together the search
engine and then you have to have some
kind of notion better
what is your architecture there and
there's the way we like to think about
is really more along the line of you
know what is the information
architecture what are you trying to
convey to the user that the user is
going to see right so then we say well
you know we actually would like to
design the latest one and from being and
the that what we do is actually three
columns layout so we still have the
traditional URL results is still at is
the most prominent space that's what is
people mostly still looking for that's
what we call this a web nose and the we
are going to extend is the middle one
what we call the pink nose and it's
really mostly about the entities in the
monologist know what we do here and this
is a the far right is actually what we
call the what friends know so that's
actually how we think about those three
different ways to do things it's not
like we can about the mix but we would
rather start this whole thing by being
very clear to the user what you can
expect again you know it's kind of
training the user to get your point then
you know the feedback you get from the
user makes even more sense so you say
you have web notes the traditional web
results plus some answers and then we
have the entities knowledge is there
then you say that you have the using the
social data in a from social norm
Facebook Twitter in the others and we
can show a lot of interesting results
there so that's really the overall the
implementing architecture here so let me
just use the stem for example here so if
you look at the stem for now we actually
have three things actually locked in my
my
you thing and if you log on Facebook and
then I know we will be able to show you
a lot of no results no leverage in your
facebook data so on the left then you
have this what web knows and the know if
you'd have Stanford of course you want
to get the stand for her at the Stanford
University here then you have the entity
here that's what we do and then the LA
to be used for information about the
Stanford and the related people and the
people who also searched Stanford it's
kind of interesting look at that people
who stand also such the Harvard Yale
Princeton and I would assume that's
Berkeley then there on the right hand
side as if friends know and having the
friends here and I think yiling actually
you know this is also student here
Barney was a student here and some other
people also know something about the
Stanford so this is really sort of a
setup you know for my somewhat technical
talk you know how we actually really
formulate this problem and the hopefully
that's clear enough to you you know how
we really look at this problem space so
the private design is actually more
complicated more complex than I actually
I actually thought and I thought I
understood before I joined is a product
team turns out that you know put
together this search without the page is
more complexed and then I thought you
know being a technologist and the
researcher before and I just did not
understand it enough you know what's
really going on there so the way we
think about now you know put all those
things together we say well we actually
really understand that we actually have
an architecture we would like to follow
and we would like to have a model behind
how we actually put every piece together
on the page and this really is really a
dialogue model and if you if you care
enough to just bear with me for a few
minutes I walk you through the overall
the system that we actually think about
the modeling here it's really a stay for
feedback system it really they are in
those three three loops here and I
skipped is the big loop that is actually
why did you design this kind of product
features so it's a little bit the
abstract here I will come to the
concrete example you know after this
this slide so if you think about that so
you say well
design something and you believe that
the user behavior would be like this
then the important thing is actually you
build an a intend model say if you type
this kind of query that's how I
interpret the our intents the concept
there the topic is there and entities
there and all those things and then you
show something of course then the you
you have the page there is a user will
interact so the user goes through this
whole interact model then something
happened so then we actually say still
you know log the user behavior the from
clicks to browsing to other things then
we come back we say did this feature
really achieve what the way as you want
for example your number one result you
actually really want you have more
clicks for example your number without
you really want to have more clicks than
number two results if that's not the
case then you should to think about it
so those are really just a very simple
examples they know how we actually look
at this so that's one main loop so the
second loop here is actually what we
call the zoology and the memory here
memory is really shot and knowledge you
know you know that's another way to
really think about they say well in
order to interpret this intend and I
actually would like to have some
understanding about some things let's
take Stanford so Stanford actually turns
out to be mostly is a University and
it's also a location and also a name of
a hospital there are many things so you
have to have this kind of knowledge here
then you use that that you really infer
the intent and you can also use some of
the short-term memory like you know what
happened in the previous clear what
happened in the previous query there are
a lot of those interesting things there
you can also use so that's really
overall you know how we actually rethink
about of course it's a big loop as I
mentioned earlier is if you don't like
this design and you have another loop
you know it just changes the whole thing
so that's somewhat at a high level but
if we actually get into more details
then you say well know exactly how what
kind of dialogues did you really design
for your product and that they are very
different many different levels I just
point out a few here they could be as a
Bock human level and you can really say
a lot of things about the URL the
documents and it could be a query level
and it could be a page level and it
could be
level so there are different things so
I'll show you an example here some very
simple example and the starting with
something you should be very familiar
with if you use such ng so this thing
called the simple in the explicit query
level dialog so let's see you type
Stanford you actually want to type
Stanford it's hyper sta and no Stan F
here so for me the first result coming
up is actually stem for ease 380 now
this thing is also highlight the reason
for that is actually I I did search for
this before so that's actually my short
term memory section my switching history
here you don't have to log on Bing or
anything you we already provide that
it's actually a very very useful feature
it's actually some number you might be
curious to know it turns out that you
know if you just the logger your search
queries for the last month and then do
our statistics you should send me your
numbers you know if you don't if you
don't believe me it turns out that 50
percent of your queries that you are you
already queried it before so roughly
about a half so that's why you actually
we look at the user behavior we say well
it's actually important that it would
provide such a history here and then you
have you know a lot of you know other
suggests in the Stanford University it
stem for football and and all those
things apparently a lot of people they
actually typed so those that really from
is the aggregate the user behavior of
course anonymous so that's actually
something you see every day we call the
the autosuggest so that's the example
here i just talked about so here's the
second example we say no no stellar and
the correction here is another in a very
simple dialogue then you say you type
this thing no you really want type those
stem for
cardinal and it turns out that you
mistyped it and the reaction of st a and
d fo rd and it's just and the the spell
is smart enough basically saying well
it's probably wrong and then we actually
would like to correct that for you
including the results for no stem for
Cardinal
if you really meant no means this D here
then you can actually click that then
you get a new result a different result
so that's actually what's really
happening here and that's really my
personal favorite the feature in a
all time favorite feature with simple
line and you have this dialogue to
dissemble grid with the user say you
probably have it wrong but who knows you
might really meant that so that's really
you know what's going on there and once
you have enough online data then you
have enough statistics you actually
really know what's what's going on there
so so this is another another example
that's also interesting for certain
queries we actually have a lot of a
structured data like a camera it's a
camera where should know a lot of things
about the camera it just you know is can
be building our knowledge so I say
camera is actually in different
categories of brands the megapixels and
this is intended disambiguation here and
that is a possible intent in the camera
it could be really also meant
Kim Kim called Corliss as well then you
have the copying hand when people search
for cameras likely destroyed for brands
the megapixels and other important
attributes and then also people typed
before they actually say when they
search for cameras are also search for
some accessories so this is another
example say wow if you continue say
where you actually look for camera but
you look for an icon then you can look
at an icon and say well we actually have
some suggestions for an icon we
understand so much about an icon you
know you go from there here's the where
I actually really care about the 14
megapixel you click that we bring you to
you know more rich representation here
it actually works out really nicely for
certain queries where we actually have a
lot of structured data the challenge
there is actually data sparsity very
quickly it doesn't work for many of
those queries because you just don't
simply don't have enough structured data
to really power that in the other people
have worked on facets that you for a
long long time it never really took off
for web search because the web search
you were not really able to come up with
this kind of structure very nicely but
it doesn't work very well and as we have
tried and they're shown to the users and
it actually are especially for the
products so that really gets to a very
interesting question how we actually
really think about the formulating this
problem is in order to get the dialogue
work you have to have some kind of
notion of semantics and you really need
to get those entities right
you better start to prepare those
entities you know if you really want you
get some sense out of that so for a long
time our optimization framework was
really mostly about the query in the
document the new thing in this dialogue
Amato is really now more than if you
want to get this meaningful dialogue you
have to get into the entities so the
whole thing really becoming is a QE and
the D so the query entity and the
documents so let me just say a few words
about you know really there's a
challenges in building this kind of
semantic index in the matching system it
just there's just a lot of entities
there just really a lot of entities you
may hear from Google being and we're
announcing that in our in the knowledge
graph this knowledge graph that if we
have hundreds of millions of entities
you know what Facebook Facebook can just
come out saying you know what we have
more than a billionth it is for sure
because there are billion people there
and but do you have enough those
entities with rich data that's actually
interesting so those actually is a
challenge there so we're definitely on
the path to build knowledge for billions
of entities and documents and that we
want to understand is the trillions of
relationships so once you have the note
once you go beyond the web graph to
start to view the entity ground for
people graph and then you have a lot of
edges those edges really practical are
just relationships so then you have to
understand more those relationships and
the in order to really use that for user
tasks accomplishing then you also needed
to really try to understand the
relationship between the web graph the
people graph the entity graph I think
what we see today in our industry is
that there are very few very clean
entity graphs have been built by any
company there's some but at the very
large scale they are very few but this
is one entity graph I think is getting
better and better as we go on is really
people graph I would say everyone
probably is familiar with Facebook
people graph the recently announced they
have more than a billion people and the
billion notes but is another very
interesting people graph I would say is
a link thing probably even more chling
and probably is very interesting for
southern applications
so those things are happening as we
speak so there's very important that you
know if we want to make some sense you
know not only we want to work on those
entity graphs we just really have to
work on the relationship between the
entity graph and the web graph as well
the reason really is very simple it's
actually entity graphs as we build we
actually have got a very little feedback
with those entity graphs until recently
and they're really very little on the
other hand that we have accumulated a
lot of knowledge with web graph so it's
by leveraging that is going to be very
powerful so let me show you a couple of
examples there's entities you know this
is we get a John right this time and the
typing is name right so we look at that
snow say we're people who search the
John also such the for some other
interesting stem for people well would
you have a david hedison here I guess
they've did write a couple of books with
him
of course you know you come you don't
come to Stanford not paying enough
respect to Don Knuth I don't actually
wrote a lot of paper a lot of books we
more than those four we listed here and
I think another interesting thing we
probably should do is the list the
numerous awards you want and including
what we announced today at the reception
so the interesting things you can do the
challenge there is actually it's not
clear and how much you should really put
it here even so the the query is pretty
clear photonic news and the Don has
hundreds of those attributes associated
with this entity which ones we should
show you know what people really
interested they are interested what
people are searching for so those things
are still is a relevance problem as
we'll go on here's another interesting
example say who won the Oscar for the
best actress in 2011 turns out is
Natalie Portman so the movies she has
worked on and those related to people
others also searched so they are really
when you talk about entities they are
really the people places and the things
so we talked a lot of other people and
the Lady Gaga this is actually
interesting so Lady Gaga's and we
actually have this music deal with a lot
of providers if you search for Lady Gaga
we actually pop up a few very popular
songs
lady gaga and I has had you can even
click here in the launch into our player
and you can start to listen so places
and among errors is interesting and so
the things so that not only we actually
have this particular movie and that we
actually have cast and the reviews and
the so forth and they have many other
things you can imagine that you know you
SS nummies I if you're interesting those
big boats and those are queries that you
you might look for so those are really
entities that we have been building and
I think the whole industry is moving
towards that direction you know we are
not alone so I do want to say something
about really understanding the intent as
well as we really continue to move on to
design this dialogue model so what's
really unique about the search engine is
that people are willing to give you a
few words give you a phrase and there's
something that in his or her mind so
it's extremely important that you know
how much we can understand not only
lexically but also semantically well
what this use is really trying to say it
turns out that in order to really
understand we actually have to take
advantage of a lot of contextual
information and I just to show you three
very interesting dimensions one is not
at a time in the temporal and they are
let's just say particularly example this
you know people here write the papers I
don't know what is the the latest are
conference coming up with and when you
see DPR deadlines it just passed in the
cvpr if you type cvpr now versus cvpr
later and which CVP are you looking for
is actually can be very different in
that so this is this time time dimension
here is this suddenly this is the
location in the spatial dimension here
are you type a library in Seattle and
you probably want to get to King County
Library System if you're type library in
New York City and it's very very
different I think those things actually
search engines getting better and better
by using reverse IP and other
informations or registration under those
things
but one particularly dimension actually
we feel extremely excited about is
actually social it's actually a piece of
data is getting bigger and bigger and
it's getting to be very interesting and
if you are willing to log on and you are
willing to share this information in the
with Facebook with Bing then there's
lots that we can really help you out and
you may want to do that anyway because
if you have a question it's not only you
can do you know by asking search engine
this question you probably would do you
know in a normal social setting asking
some of the friends I have to admit not
all the friends on Facebook are really
friends but you know what I mean
so you can ask other people's opinions
so let me talk a little bit about this
social thing so if you have enough this
kind of social stuff then you can
actually think about different ways to
use the social signal clearly you can
use the friends as the context as a
ranking signal and so they might have
liked something they might know
something and those things if you can
index and it would be good so friends
can also passively help you know through
the previous social actions I mentioned
about that and the friends could also
actively engage to mix the social better
and I show you some examples that and
the friends can for example tag some
information for you and the point out
the certain certain documents actually
really about you and the mention about
you and you really should be in a part
of that particular documents so I show
you some of those examples the challenge
there is of course is really difficult
you know without Siskin social data now
we have been working for 15 20 years you
know to improve the search engine and we
learned enough about the from crawling
to indexing to ranking and how difficult
it is how I should deal with all the
stems and other things are still we
struggle now you look at the social data
it's another open game and we don't
really know and how do we really even
define the social search equality and
how effective it is to plan the social
signals into the overall ranking how do
we even measure that how do we design
experiments to really evaluate the data
is just not
somewhat a nightmare and people are
typically in this kind of social social
coppers and they write very short things
and the only things and the Twitter's
definition is in the know more than 140
characters so all those challenges no we
actually have to do is it's very early
in my mind you know no by no mean and
you know we have been successful here
yet but it's the one one particular
dimension that we are very much wrong
with the close collaboration with
Facebook in particular and also with
Twitter and other social companies I'll
give you an example here just to
elaborate and a little bit that and that
you might agree with me that so she's
taken oh it's actually useful so if you
look at the Nokia Lumia 920 the latest
smartphone from Nokia then you have
those three layouts we lay the column
layout
then you actually have a particular page
here actually a friend like and how
important is it is not clear but a
friend actually liked it in this
particular page so without the
randomizer the order the ranking order
we just say we annotate we annotate this
page say you know what a friend of yours
actually said something about this page
well he or she actually liked it then
you look at here they say wow that
there's a friends and experts who
actually might know something about
Lumia 920 apparently you think the
friends actually said a lot of things
about Lumia 920 just another example say
Yein Ling and they said well you know
you have years page here and in the
middle but they said well the because he
is the friend for you things and when
you search then you actually get Ian's
the Facebook page you know pop it over
here and not only that then we actually
also say why should know something about
the Ian's there are some tact pages
about a year so latest no articles on
the web actually mention about a year
and I so actually related
you could even know click on this tak
this small pages and this really
crowdsourcing notes know by leveraging
friends just say say some do something
to help it out about a lot of pages that
Ian actually is involved so then we also
have their say actually a lot of people
actually know my know yen so if you
click that you get to this particular
page here is called
so you have this text PG here then
that's really ye and you see you know
unions picture here then they are
actually a lot of pictures a lot of
documents here previously already
attacked and you can find them all pages
attack and you can continue this
crowdsourcing to get more information
about the yen so do you already have
fifteen pages and it could certainly do
more and you can also tack you know
other friends even so this page is
already attacked no Ian is involved but
clearly there are some other colleagues
who also contributed to this thing
article here there are some text there
too
then you can find them all pages to
attack so the last example I want to
show you here is actually you know that
recent the close collaboration with
Facebook and I we continue to roll out a
new features and so one thing we
actually tried is actually figured out
you know how important it is about your
Facebook photos I don't know about you
and if you're such Harry Shum and a my
name if through such Harry Sherman with
a lot of Harry Shum pictures and they're
mostly about my previous life I used to
give talks here and there and are
practically you know pretty old pictures
my latest pictures mostly actually on
Facebook and I'm not that public person
and I'm not posting a lot of pictures
there I have about 40 pictures but those
40 pictures at least that you me no more
fairly represented in my life in the
last five years so it's a lot very
interesting things there so we actually
have this in a facebook friends the
photo search here if we search in a San
Francisco on being like a you teen
lockdown and actually you think God a
lot of people are you post a lot of
interesting things about the San
Francisco and yeah so there are many
other examples you can imagine so I'm
going to summarize my talk and finish
this talk and by saying that such is a
fascinating space such really are is the
research problem in my mind and this
long-term battle and there is a long
term commitment to really build in the
bestest search quality that's the
quality search engine and Google is
incredibly strong and being ahead of you
know anyone
for a long time but the beam is coming
behind and hopefully we give Google run
of money and if nothing else who will
keep a Google very honest about the
search results in order to do that and
that we have to really build is a core
experience right the relevance has to be
good such quality has to be good and
more and more you know we think about
this core experience as a task a
completion here and the secondly I would
say the the way we actually have been
thinking about hopefully it has been
clear to you you know how we have been
thinking about is really with the
guidance of this the information
architecture you know with this three
column design of being know the web
knows being those friends know and the
communicates the information that you
are looking for the model we have is
really this dialog and the way we do
that is we have to get into more
semantics we have to get into more
entities and knowledge we must have this
intent and interaction together again
it's really long battle and I hope that
you know we have more people in Stanford
and OH start to use being and give us
more feedback I know you all have been
waiting for questions ask a question
please here sure like the dialogue man
yeah how do you make sure that users
acknowledge it and use it and don't keep
on treating it just like the ten
feelings I'm not sure I accomplished
other question when we introduced a new
feature how do you use this notice it
yes and how do you make sure that sort
of the just the average non power users
ah right so that's a very good question
so how do we know you know when we
rolled out of the feature actually the
users actually noticed and the users
actually use so the good thing about sin
the working on any kind of online
products is that you actually have a
chance to collect a lot of user data of
course again you have to be careful in
the anonymous and all those things in
there but you actually have a chance to
especially look how to aggregate the
data like a cute example is one thing we
actually care a lot is called the
click-through rate so if you have a
feature that is clickable and let's just
say the stonk lose the example there in
the tall
there's at four four books we put there
how do we know if that's effective
well we actually just need to compare if
those four books got clicked and by
design I actually would assume that is
the one that is very left get a click
them more and they so all those kind of
things we do the entry model if it's not
then we will revisit and though we go
from there but there are plenty of
signals that we can have and the clicks
through is one very good thing the other
very common private that we used
actually is through our time you know
someone go to a page you know did the he
or she stay there long enough then you
more or less know it's a it's a good
heuristic yeah what friends know and
yeah now you're integrating with
Facebook so how do you deal with the
crossover from a privacy perspective
because search engine right you're
pulling in relevant data
yeah that's a fantastic question though
we take a privacy extremely no seriously
the way we do that is actually we have
our privacy policy you know how we
actually communicated with users what
they had to use them prompts you know
before we use turn this feature so
that's the Bing side because we
collaborate very closely with Facebook
we also have the Facebook side of the
privacy concerns as well so everything
we do with Facebook data we strictly
follow faithful to privacy policy as
well and in terms of for example that
one very interesting thing you can say
is that when you log on Facebook in each
ion beam and the one thing you probably
notice that the number of your friends
is actually smaller than showing you on
being in there is actually smaller than
the number of friends you see on your
Facebook the reason for that is actually
a lot of your friends actually turned on
some permission that you actually don't
see that for example I don't see that I
don't see my wife Mary she's just a very
strict about it no privacy so so so we
we actually take that very very
seriously
yeah yeah Jr oh my goodness Harry Shum
sucks
intent yeah how detailed yeah this
example is you type in a query next
train to Boston yep
now if in fact there's a train strike
then you'd like to get well the answer
is a train strike but as the you know
and so forth
yeah for this you need to model things
reading the very detailed way about what
is the plan of it yeah and so on I would
say we are very early and is a great
question I get to your main question let
me make a quick comment on Harry show me
example
so I actually challenged my team and I
actually have this officer Harry Shum
challenge there in the in the bean team
and it's really about the name
disambiguation or entity assembly in
general I used to be somebody long time
ago when you search the for Harry Shum
you know Harry Shum from Microsoft
Microsoft Research did pop up at number
one
then later on something happened is the
guy's name is Harry Shum Jr no relation
to me and it's that answer and there is
an incredible now you can see that on
YouTube and there and also he plays in
this apparently very popular TV series
called Glee so he's that is actually in
glee so so girls we just look at the guy
in the screen and so he actually became
very popular and it was continue to move
up actually he did move up even faster
in Google than the peanuts and they
pushed me down further but that really
is that is something I have no problem
with that systemically and there I think
the parts in order to get back to the
user to me I think the important
dylon importance in really thing is
really the dialogue because we now know
there are two dominant
reasonably dominant entity all relate to
Harry Shawn is the Harry Shum Microsoft
the Harry engineer and just have to
present that back to the user see do you
really mean the should list and all you
mean is the computer scientists so so
that's the that's really you know
something we really need to do but if
you actually there's a different which
we really solve that a problem I would
say you have is that using social signal
for those people who actually care
enough about the harry shum of microsoft
can provide if you and I are connected
on Facebook which we have not yet if we
are connected if you lock on Facebook
your search harry shum the first result
will be your friend Harry Shum and the
Facebook so at least that you get that
part right and we can imagine a lot of
things we can do from there then back to
your main question about this the
overall the intent I think we're far
from that I actually I'm not confident
that is the current architecture will
take us there
and by that I really mean both Google
and Bing and the buying a large the
apparatus the incredible system will
have built it's still more or less you
know what to what to do with the web
graph it's very little understanding and
about the scene tender and we're making
some aggressive push there but as you
can see and you can try you go home you
can try being in a try some queries so
we're really not there yet my worry is
actually you know if we are to
aggressively in terms of pushing a lot
of those interns like your famous
example is say you know when is the next
train to Boston I as you said I could be
twenty five hours away and it does you
does really involve multiple layers of
understanding of the intent in the
getting there in the building a lot of
knowledge about the train schedule
understand the context about your
location and the so force the direction
is clear that we're moving towards that
but the the current user interface in
the simple wide apart who is one line
very likely will need to be changed to
accommodate that together and the people
start to use speech for example in but
I'm not sure that is necessarily and a
shortcut to get there you
the click-through rates yeah one of the
more successful types of retargeting is
because yes yes absolutely
um that's more context is that the sort
of context you're looking for sort of
look at their other behavior not just
their search behavior Facebook yeah well
first of all we just say that you know
you need to be very careful when you
track people that behavior and a lot of
those things Center you really need to
do that in a transparent a respectful
way and that you really need to
communicate with user what kind of data
you use and that I think is that in our
industry now are they you know there are
a lot of you know discussing going on
and they look at the major browsers now
they are implements I think a finally I
feeling chrome is doing that do not
track policy at least you give the user
some choice there now if you see the
willing to opting is really to give you
a lot of data I think this is actually
very very used for the powerful data and
as you said that rightly so ads
retargeting has been so powerful and you
went to some other website in the
looking for some kind of the truck and
now by the time you search for some
things here and the search engine
doesn't know more about you if you can
aggregate this kind of information and
then you need to do that carefully it is
very powerful and there are the
contextual information I would say has
not been as successful in such compared
wasting ads in my opinion for a very
simple reason that is such quality in
general is much higher because this
country tagging scene is really mostly
are more recommendation and they're so
the quality if the quality is more
comparable to ads and it's likely people
will click more but it's the quality is
the significant lower than search so
solving a problem with at best they're
never there when you want to see them
that's a problem but I would say largely
agree I would say that's particularly
true for display ad for such ads is
significantly better quality compared
with
display ads because you do give some
intent choose the search engine and that
we can optimize but as I already stated
that even in such such ads quality is
significant lower than search results
yeah yeah I sometimes find the Google
results to the Chinese just which I
cannot read and do you have any comments
under that that improving the quality
Ling adaptability for the such I am not
sure I completely got your question you
are saying that you know you you
actually search some Japanese query and
you actually got the results with the
Chinese results yeah and from Google
Japanese page yeah without knowing a lot
of details my suspicion that you
probably should have set your market and
the language you write maybe you should
have give you the try and it doesn't
sound right and it sounds like it's some
simple things you are you searching here
all right searching Japan what you think
if you say so here's the thing so what
what the search engines typically do is
they say well you know the a couple of
things you should really set I know I
use searching United States are you
searching English and you can still such
a United States and such Japanese and
the you can be in Japan such English as
well so depending on the market and the
language setting and it's actually
reasonable is sophisticated and you have
these things through and typically the
the search engines will optimize towards
the majority of the users what they are
really looking for and I give you an
example that you know I'm personally
more familiar with say in China in China
someone in China's such a term called
the Jackie Chan is a confused stop and
what type the Jackie Chan in English
Jackie Chan should we serve the user
completely English content or should we
serve the use of some Chinese content so
turns out for Korea like Jackie Chan
most of the time the Chinese users in
China still want to see significant the
Chinese content even so the query is
Jackie Chan so for those things you
have to learn that you can flight you
can just say you know why don't we just
give some answers you know all English
um use the Chinese plus English and that
we do those things so that's active but
the or experience seems to be a little
bit is surprising to me and uh you might
want to check your settings language in
the market settings
yeah sometimes did you messed up at the
back how was that how much is being
dialogue was contributed by power set is
this uh for those of you who don't know
I actually acquired a company called the
power setting calm and there was a
pioneer in natural language search
company and I actually should a party's
name earlier found it was a Stanford
graduate and they're very successful
entrepreneur so the lot of technologies
from power said actually now you know in
the core engine of our being and I would
say we made a significant contribution
to not only what we can already share
today but also shaped a lot of our
thinking's so I would say you know
there's really ii ii a lot of natural
language the technology the itself it's
already in the changing yeah they seem
to have focus more on get the exact
right price right point you score if you
do right and what you're saying here is
what we really need is a dialogue system
in which people can refine the questions
and yeah i actually understand what they
need to ask together do you think what
would you think would be a good metric
to measure
dialogue system accuracy by that's a
very difficult question you know I often
say that the metrics team I should
always are usually just say I go to
every team I work with multiple teams
and every team I ask so who is your
metrics guy and typically I would say
who has high psych you in this team and
they want you to put this guy on metrics
this is such a difficult problem and
it's not very cleared I wish I can give
you a high level answer what I said
before is really with this dialogue
thing
the right metric is really the time to
complete the task so you have one step
two step so remember is that until now
the the competition say get is the
relevance thing and get it the fast so
you minimize the query in the URL
matching now that's what will be always
the core but that's really the game so
far but now you're saying well you know
what let's say you know one search
engine takes you know nine hundred
milliseconds versus the other one takes
say 700 milliseconds that's really no
big deal if you actually compare with
say this is a changing only requires you
to do two searches the other search
engine actually needs you to do three
search engine so then I think that's how
you really think about the difference
and how to measure the effectiveness of
dialogue model yeah most the difficult
frontier and challenge in search is
actually not text-based search is let's
say right right has cracked yes what's
her comment on that is Microsoft trying
to is your ping yeah yeah so that's a
very good question the question is
that's you know we talked a lot about
backspace to search you know what about
the image base the content based in the
image is search for example now show
someone a picture can you find something
similar the couple of things I can share
with you number one is that that where
she tried a few things this first one we
actually ever try it is actually was
done by my students in Beijing was
really something called finding similar
images my favorite example is actually
you type a query called event goal and
then you have all these paintings coming
up in images such now he said well I
look at those pictures say I actually
like some flowers a lot then you click
on those one of those images say you
know can I find them all similar images
like this the boom just like that
then you get all the sunflower pictures
there doesn't work at okay you know a
lot of people actually kind of like that
but overall and the in terms of user
experience we have not found
you know people's needs for
content-based research that high so
that's actually a little bit
disappointing to me as a vegan person I
would thought that that people just say
look at wow my goodness you know why
don't we get this thing I guess that
that is just not really clear the intent
there say what did you mean by finding
simulate images and let's just say you
can find similar images so what's the
next task for you
who is that meet you to do what I think
is something there I think it probably
for Google and us you know something to
be desired and it's not clear but be
good to compare those two is that Google
engineers you know how they actually
think about this although although the
other feature we had we have was
actually finding the same image but with
different sizes and a lot of users
there's a lot of people are to use that
yes yeah so you have a question yeah
actually you know you mentioned the
competition most people realize that
Larry and Sergey wrote Google yeah their
classmate Luisa Gravano actually invited
everybody who wrote a search engine
including your own Microsoft people yeah
yeah and so learning Sergey she could
have benefited a lot from Louie's
reading those guys I'm sure but I'm
curious how you think both you haven't
mentioned yeah okay well maybe I just
add some comments that you know I you
guys probably don't know and I worked
very closely with Stephen Wolfram for
three years and we actually had a deal
with them when you popped up you know
quite a bit you know wolf em results
yeah on thing and it was way before in a
Google knowledge graph and other things
and it became more popular we actually
try to you can still go to him calm and
the try there's a beautiful site I told
the Steven that you know he has two big
fans in my family and me and my son you
know when we work on some calculus
problems so we still really use the
Wolfram
but for a lot of an entity kind of a
queries I think are they are interesting
but they are not interesting enough for
general users I think they're trying and
the for example the
I believe that I hope that's public
knowledge I believe that they do power a
number of scenarios for Siri for
instance and there's a lot of things
that did you very well the I still come
back to my main cities here you know
that I'm a big believer of this dialogue
Amato and I just feel that today our
technology is not really there and I get
back to you have questions that we're
really not there to just give you asking
me a person give you that I mean you can
feel lucky every day but you don't
really get everything you aren't looking
for a and B in just being very realistic
year yes now that Google has taught us
to use pigeon and Bain has followed suit
but is there any chance for natural
language where you can actually say what
your intent is is never gonna do that oh
my goodness I really want to do that and
that we really really want it I don't
see Chris here this morning I actually
spent a 30-some minutes who is there
Chris hanging and talking about the
power of an excellent we love natural
language let's be very good we love
machine learning we have we have been on
this thing but they are hard to use and
you know if you look at if we follow I
assume you do your nails if we follow
the progress of the natural language you
know over the years and its really the
success for scenarios the examples are
really database so the data treatment
it's really mostly a lot of progress
there and over the years and really you
have a lot of data you know you try to
leverage a lot of data I really get
there and we leverage it for example you
know statistic machine translations
significantly you know it's just the
beyond what I can talk about here is
that it's really helped so those things
in the really really matters but the
problem is that problem is that is that
when you say you know why didn't you use
more and say natural languages stuff we
should do we certainly do we try to use
a lot of things the question is really
saying what is the use a scenario what
are the kind of queries that we can
answer better by using what statistical
natural language processing methods to
really help and so we take a very
practical approach here right now is
basically we're saying we really need to
No do is boast the queries and this
documents to get some sense of that
someone asked me about the powerset we
actually the processed natural language
processing a lot of process in there and
really try to understand the more about
the relationships in animism and the
other things in the from for example is
a very high quality product called
Wikipedia so we did a lot of those
things and we found that the
contribution you know from those serious
process of the documents has not
translated to significant the game in
terms of overall search quality so on
the other hand natural and natural
language processing of the queries start
to really show a lot of power there if
you really get some entities right even
though it's only a very short phrase and
then you really get the right in a way I
would say you know give credit to say
Stephen Wolfram what does the move from
did for example is whatever your
question you ask I will get your entity
long in the entity right then I prepare
a lot of you for me to say danke lose as
long as these questions about the time I
just boom give you every step at a time
you go find anything related on Todd's
birthday in the tunnels books and
lectures everything awards yeah we are
just we can we we are on I don't know if
I can give you the answer that I heard
from you have this afternoon and I think
a Syria I think a Siri is a fantastic
product and they are very interesting
and pointing out this is a direction but
it's not like a direction we never heard
before
I think is it's a long term technology
battle and we get to certain point
speech recognition aside and let me just
say you know in terms of natural
language understanding query
understanding intend understanding to
really answers the kind of questions I'd
love to talk to anyone who actually
regularly use a Serie B on one
particular scenario I just I'd love to
you know you for anyone here I assume
that you know people in Silicon Valley
are mostly I've I phone users and I'd
love to hear from you you know how
useful you found in a series and I think
the direction is right I actually gue is
doing pretty well and they look at the
yeah so now they have a lot of Stanford
graduates they better do well so
you